Ich möchte es zu machen.
Alles, was einmal culturesiv zu tun Hmmmm
und wieso ich hier bin virginisieren werde,
die Reifzeit der Altenheit
Stimmt.
Ich bin die Altenheit.
so moin leute bin am start ich hoffe ihr seid ausgeschlafen
pack nerbe anscheinend nicht
wir gucken uns jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen wach werden, ich bin gerade aufgestanden
wir gucken uns jetzt mal so wach werden, ein ground war tactical new gameplay, der typisch
übertrieben gut, das ist mittlerweile der lieblings cod channel den ich gucke, der macht
kein gelaber, der macht einfach nur gameplay plus das was er so live erzählt bei, erzählt
nicht dass er 40 bitches weggecockt hat und erzählt nicht irgendwelche krumme, er macht
keine slots oder irgendwas, dann spielt er einfach nur und da haben wir ein bisschen
dabei, den gucke ich mittlerweile echt am liebsten
ich werde dabei mal ein bisschen was, nicht kaffee, ein bisschen tee trinken, kaffee trinke
ich ja nicht, weiß nicht warum ich gerade kaffee sagen wollte
die bitches hast du dieses morgens weggecockt, dieses oder alle wochenende zusammen
ich hab hillstreaks gemacht, das muss reichen
oh er hat das mal nachkommentiert, das macht er normalerweise nie
ok gucken wir mal, noob auflösung, dafür schöne fps, so muss das sein
allerdings hier sieht man auch schön das problem bei youtube bei 1080p, youtube 1080p ist halt
kack bitrate, was man hier auch glaube ich sieht irgendwo
wo ist die bitrate, die man die bitrate von dem video
ich meine das ist ja alles ganz interessant aber die bitrate ist eigentlich das was dich
interessiert und der ganze andere krempel nicht
ne, das ist nicht die bitrate, ne die bitrate steht da nicht drinne
ja aber das dürfte so die typischen 6,7 mbit sein für 1080p und das ist einfach zu wenig
bei youtube, man siehts ja auch pixeln
ok gucken wir uns mal an wie das alle außen, m4 spielte, m4 beste waffe, m4 spiel ich auch
immer, ne moment ist das m4, ja das ist m4, m4 beste, alle aufsätze sind irgendwie crap
also alle aufsätze die ads und movement speed langsamer machen, deswegen auch optics, da
kann man sich vielleicht vor seinem bildschirm gunner optic classes anziehen aber ein optics
auf das gewehr drauf machen, zack, das heißt außer er hat einen schalldämpfer drauf, ein
schalldämpfer bin ich nicht drauf, dem glaube ich auch gar nix
oi zebaro, ist das ps4, ja ps4, zebaro hast wieder zu viel weggecockt oder was, oder was
ist los hier, mit dem physik grill, nee, ah kids batman, slap a like, das erinnert mich
immer an diesen bass typ, slap like now, omg, man kommt mit dem heli aufs dach, ich hab
keinen anderen weg gefunden als mit dem heli aufs dach, falls jemand den offiziellen weg
kennt sagt bescheid, weil hinten ist ne reeling, da müsste man, also ich mein da ist halt
ein weg, da ist halt ein weg den man laufen kann, das heißt es ist gedacht dafür drauf
zu kommen, also es gibt bestimmt nen richtigen, was über die kisten an der seite, ok, nice,
also die meisten machen es aber mit dem heli, die meisten leute siehst du am anfang der
runde in den heli springen und ja dann halt da auf dem dach landen und in heli crashen,
kisten an der seite, ich muss mir das mal angucken, ich muss vor allem auch mal gucken
gibt es die möglichkeit, dass man irgendwie die map sich mal offline anguckt, ja ja es
gibt nen heli, in ground war gibt es nen heli, kannst du rein, aber die leute benutzen den
heli in ground war genauso wie, zeigs mal im stream, ich kanns ja grad nicht zeigen,
weil es wahrscheinlich keinen offline modus gibt, es gibt nen heli aber den verwenden
die leute, die meisten leute genauso beknackt wie in battlefield, nämlich hochfliegen mit
dem heli aufs dach und in heli crashen, ja richtig die noobs fliegen in heli, wir haben
grad übrigens 69 zuschauer, huge, musst auf die kisten und dann gegen das dach springen,
leertaste spammer, leertaste spammer, ok also man klitscht nicht durch dach, das ist wirklich
ein weg der gedacht ist, ok muss ich mal nachher ausprobieren, tat gestern übrigens auch
ein übelst nice gameplay auf ground war, irgendwie 48,9 oder sowas, voll gebashed mit support
heli, vitoll und uav, die killstreaks haben sogar richtig gut was gekillt, oh das kann
ich nicht aussprechen, die ana 0xtkpq45ula, ahja alles klar twitch prime huge, ok, ok
nice, haste discord gesehen, dann winos98wit konnte man als vorschlag auf youtube bei elotrics
im stream sehen, außerdem hat er überlegt, wie in der hausart auch dich erwähnt, na gut
das man ein video im vorschlag sieht ist jetzt ja nicht so selten, wo kommt der eigentlich
wieder her, der war jetzt irgendwie gefühlt 3 jahre in der versenkung verschwunden, länger
als ich, in der versenkung verschwunden und jetzt ist er auf einmal wieder da, muss er
nur noch videos hochladen, er wollte wieder durchschlagen, ok dann bin ich ja mal gespannt,
guck habt ihrs hier gesehen, hier sind auf dem dach diese ganzen leitern und treppen,
das heißt es ist gewollt, dass man da hinkommt, m4 beste, m4 schalldämpfer muss ich auch
ausprobieren, ich hab bisher den sinnvollen schalldämpfer in dem game noch nicht gecheckt,
weil der minimap hat ja nichts mehr zu tun, moin dragstream, warum heißt du eigentlich
dragstream, das hört schon irgendwie nach müll an, irgendwie dragstream, mich beleidigen
alter, in your face, ban ist raus, wahrscheinlich heißt es aber ganz was anderes, das hab ich
bloß jetzt falsch ausgesprochen, vitron am start schon, dragstream hat es euch mit einem
vorstellungsgespräch geklappt, es ist so ein riesen unterschied zwischen ps4 und pcr,
wenn man das sieht wie die gegner sterben und wie man trifft ist das wahnsinn, ich bin
hin und her gerissen zwischen munitionskiste und stopping power rounds, weil die munitionskiste
ist eigentlich immer praktisch und ist auch schnell da, die stopping power rounds sind
aber übertrieben brutal, die gefühlt one shotten die gegner eher, also du schießt einmal
drauf tot, die sache ist bloß die die halten nicht so lang, also alles in allem finde ich
die munitionskiste viel besser, aber stopping power ist halt für den instant bash besser,
ja knerbeer, das ist auf dem pc wird es wahrscheinlich wieder instant verhackt sein, aber wenn modern
warfare auf dem pc wieder so krass verhackt ist, dann werden eh alle konsolenleute erstmal
crossplay ausschalten, weil die keinen bock auf den scheiß haben und dann spiele ich einfach
ps4, da schließe ich meinen mouse konverter an und schieße auf der ps4, eats, eats kills,
ja die dachspots sind übrigens richtig ok, da haben wir gestern auch mal 5 bis 10 minuten
drauf rumgelegen und da killte ich halt meistens nichts, der könnte mal seinen detail was
er hat, aber garantiert ghost, garantiert ghost, gs4 1a, echt mit der jogginghose dreckstrimm,
also jeans, ich würde jeans anziehen, ich ziehe keinen anzug ran oder so, ah der hat extended
max dran, das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben, das wollte ich nämlich auch ausprobieren,
ich habe keine extended max dran, weil es die ads time verringert, und man hat eigentlich
genug munition um 2-3 gegner zu killen mit der m4, moment kann man da hochklettern, muss
ich gleich mal ausprobieren nachher, wie der offizielle weg, knapp knapp knapp knapp,
ich wäre jetzt gestorben, ich habe immer glück wenn ich angehitted werde sterbe ich
dann noch random danach, ich fühle mit ihm, er sollte sein, wie toll irgendwie mal auf
d oder so schmeißen, wie toll ist der beste kills für den ganzen game, wie toll ist richtig
op, 7 kills mit hardline, 8 kills wobei hardline verwendet kein match, jeder verwendet ghost,
8 kills die du in crown war wenn du ganz wenn du posi hast, halbwegs gut erreicht und das
ding killt alter, also der wie toll ist richtig geil, der ist auch in domination und so richtig
gut, der ist quasi wieder, der ist nicht ganz so gut wie der harrier in modern warfare 2
im solo zeugs killen, aber dadurch dass du den rumkommandieren kannst nachdem er da ist,
was du mit dem harrier nicht konntest, ist der wie toll richtig op, der beste kills streak
im ganzen game, für das was er braucht an punkten und was er bringt, wie toll ist der
wie toll, ppegaspruch, ja aber richtig ppegaspruch, oh das ist eine gute, da muss ich mal kurz
was zu sagen, die schaffen es pupge, apex und andere battle royale in einem vernünftigen
anti cheat system zu highern und cot mit 100 mal mehr kolle kriegen ist nicht geschehen,
die wollen einfach nicht, ganz einfach, die wollen nicht, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
als so die letzten paar cots auf steam erschienen sind, wo sie gesagt haben, call of duty ist
zu modern für steam anti cheat und deswegen verwenden sie kein anti cheat, weil es zu
modern ist, das war auch richtig ppega, unglaublich dämliches gelaber, es ist scheiß egal, ob
das spiel x64 ist, das anti cheat kann ohne problem x32 sein, das ist überhaupt kein
ding, ihr dacht ihr, wie es funktioniert, andere spiele kriegen das auch hin, wirklich überhaupt
kein problem, aber die erzählen halt viel, wenn der tag lang ist und ist halt viel bullshit
dabei, die wollen einfach nicht richtig oder sie haben keine fähigen leute, man muss nämlich
auch sagen, map designer haben sie auch keine gescheiten, guckt euch die maps in modern
warfare an, guckt euch diese map an, diese map ist das beste beispiel von, die haben eigentlich
eine ganz gute idee, was wir gameplay mäßig wollen, wir haben aber keine leute, die gescheiten
maps machen, warum wollen die nicht wahrscheinlich, weil es geld kostet, geld kostet und dauerhafte
pflege braucht, das anti cheat ist ja nichts, was du einfach mal erstellst und dann ist
es da, ich will nicht wissen, wie viele leute an wak sitzen, jeden tag und wak updaten,
dass wak funktioniert und er selbst bestimmt nicht, moin max 5602, 10.000 pfeifer in der
wak sitzen an wak, ja genau, wak ist ja schon teils ai, ja, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
ich hab es mal wieder predicted, ich hab vor 2 oder 3 jahren ein video gemacht, wo ich
gesagt hab, dass man in zukunft viel viel schwieriger cheaten kann, wenn die anfangen
ai basierte stats auswertungen und gameplay verhalten und sowas zu machen und das wird
immer besser, also die letzten berichte, die ich gelesen habe, ist cs go gar nicht mehr
so schlimm was cheater angeht, soll wohl drastisch gesunken sein, aber immer noch viel, es gab
ja auch vorher extrem viel, jetzt gibt es halt nur noch viel, wisst ihr was die unsinnigste
anti cheat software aller zeiten gewesen ist, das da, das ist die unsinnigste anti cheat
software aller zeiten, esl anti cheat, ja das da, wenn ich das schon sehe, ich seh ja
bitcoin miner, die haben echt ein bitcoin miner drinnen, aber das ist wirklich die schlechteste
anti cheat lösung und damals als wir noch overwatch gespielt haben in der esl war es
so, du musstest für die weekly cups musstest du overwatch starten mit der esl anti cheat
software und das problem war, das ging regelmäßig nicht und da konnten wir die turniere nicht
weiterspielen, weil die esl anti cheat software overwatch nicht gestartet hat und dann kam
dann irgendwann ein admin und hat gemeint, so nachdem, der ja startet es einfach ohne
anti cheat, da sieht man aber wie wichtig das ist, vor allem in overwatch bei release,
wo eh zumindest in europa relativ wenig cheater am start waren, war anders im vergleich zu
korea, jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal seine nuke fertig an, ich würde aber sagen, crown
war ist potenziell der einfachste modus für die nuke, potenziell, je nachdem, mal gucken
wenn die leute anfangen zu lernen wie man das spielt, nach crown war krieg sogar ich
40 plus kill gameplays hin, hast 50 kill, wisst ihr was richtig cool wäre, wo ich es hier
oben gerade sehe, was richtig cool wäre, wenn man auf 3 uav und auf 4 counter uav oder umgedreht
hätte, oder wenn man die möglichkeit hätte, einen killstreak der auf 3 ist auf 4 zu upgraden,
sodass man ihn nehmen könnte, der typ hat das ganze game auf dem dach gekämpft, ja anders
da kriegst du in dem game auch keinen 30er killstreak, es sei denn du spielst gegen absolut
brainless gegner, guckt euch mal die nuke von korean savage an, die gegner sind absolut
brainless, das ist wahrscheinlich reverse boosted bis zum, keine hände bracket oder
so, gegen gescheite gegner in diesem game kriegst du keine nuke, wenn du offensiv spielst
finde den sound geil von dem airstrike, aber der airstrike selbst sackt, der airstrike
cutpunch bis erst ein kill oder so, alter der sniper, warum hat der noch nicht gesnipert,
ich habe einen streak, ich habe einen streak, also
der müsste doch gleich eine nuke haben, ich habe jetzt die nicht gesehen, aber er hat
3 kills, alter pepega gegner, ich wäre gestorben 1 vor nuke, ich wäre 1 vor nuke gestorben,
weil ich irgendeinen scheiß gebaut hätte, vom dach gefallen oder so, wie dass ich freu
ein, ja löst das ding aus und gut ist, und die nuke rein, ich finde es auch doof, dass
es kein sound kippt für die nuke, du wirst schon mal, ja das haben sie tatsächlich ganz
cool gemacht, die nuke fliegt runter, ist so der spielstil ist nicht schön, aber was
willst du machen in dem game, das ist auch der grund warum ich ehrlich gesagt keinen
bock habe auf tryhard nuke geschichten zu spielen, weil mir fällt es eh schon schwer
mich zu bewegen, mich nicht zu bewegen, und dann muss ich 30 kills in einer des grits
halt ich nicht aus, ich kann euch leider die gameplays nicht zeigen von gestern, gestern
hatten wir richtig coole fast 50 kills gameplays und halt schon mit ein bisschen bewegen dabei
und nicht die ganze zeit auf dem dach liegen, das ist schon ziemlicher, ziemlicher Mist,
und genau deswegen funktioniert battlefield in cod nicht, ich finde diesen modus übrigens
auch nicht sonderlich toll, der wird überall gelobt, weil ich finde das wirkt ein bisschen
wie gewollt und nicht gekonnt dieser ground war modus, hast du hardstorm gespielt, ja
aber in letzter zeit nicht mehr, ich finde der ground war modus wirkt ein bisschen wie
gewollt und nicht gekonnt, wir machen einfach eine große map, klatschen ganz viele häuser
hin und irgendwelche kisten, die map sieht halt echt wieder aus, wie aus dem klo gezogen
oder als hätte irgendwie der level designer, der noch nie ein level gemacht hat, was gemacht
da und dann stellen wir da ein paar fahrzeuge drauf, die sich die übelst rumklitschen,
sobald du sie mit maus und tastatur steuerst, die fahrzeuge sind richtig kaputt, der turret
auf dem panzer, wenn du den drehst, also wenn du den turret so drehst, dreht er sich halb
schnell, wenn du den turret so drehst, dreht er sich ultra langsam, also umso schneller
du die maus drehst, umso langsamer dreht sich der turret auf dem panzer, das ist halt voll
woodface, versteht es null, also ich habe auf youtube ganz viel gesehen, amazing, perfect
mod, bla bla bla, aber ich finde der ground war ist ein bisschen wie gewollt und nicht
gekonnt, passt irgendwie auch nicht so richtig, ich habe es ja gestern im video gesagt, es
fehlt da schon so ein bisschen die maps und vor allem so die finesse, was so ein battlefield
ausmacht, ich meine, du kannst nicht einfach eine große map 32 vs 32 machen und alles
beibehalten, ja in battlefield hast du medics, die dich wiederbeleben können und sowas, du
hast ordentlich verteilte objectives, ich meine guckt euch mal die c-fahne an, die c-fahne,
der capture radius für die fahnen ist ultra klein auf ground war, der ist so klein, dass
jede flagge, vor allem c, der übelste clusterfuck auf beiden seiten ist, das einzige, was halbwegs
vergleichbar ist, sind irgendwelche fahnen auf locker oder metro oder so in battlefield
und die sind besser als das, was die da gebastelt haben, was ist in dem china ordner, aliexpress
zeug und joshi musik
bester song
echt geiles game gewesen
da gibt es bestimmt noch die 10 stunden version, aber die beste 10 stunden version ist immer
noch das hier
irgendwie schläfert sich ein, das ist wie wenn du hypnotisiert wirst, da kann man übrigens
im kott immer schön synchron zum sound schießen bei, was auch immer, danke für die beste
10 stunden version, ich wünsche euch ein schönes kott, ich wünsche euch ein schönes kott,
ich wünsche euch ein schönes kott, ich wünsche euch ein schönes kott, ich wünsche euch
euch ein schönes kott, ich wünsche euch ein schönes kott, ich wünsche euch ein schönes
kott, ich wünsche euch ein schönes kott, ich wünsche euch ein schönes kott, ich wünsche
Das sollte jetzt wahrscheinlich schon mal so 30 Kilo gehen oder so, mehr, noch mehr.
Wahrscheinlich reißt jetzt die Kordel, 35 Kilo, na ist kaputt gegangen, 35 Kilo, ich
meine es ist poplische Lego Zeugs, ja die Gesundheitsakten, den Vortrag hab ich gesehen
zu den Gesundheitsakten, oh, ja vorbei, da muss er, da muss er seine Metallachse jetzt
nehmen vom letzten Video, ja normale Zahnräder sind schon besser, guck mal wie sich das Zeug
verbiegt, das ist kurz vor dem platzen, ja nicht damit gerechnet, ja auch nicht, na doch
sonntags morgens ist der einzige feste Tag an dem ich streme oder fest, so traditionell
hat sich das schon irgendwie eingeschliffen so, bisschen Lego Ölen, ja das macht er auch
manchmal, das macht er auch manchmal, da macht er so ein bisschen Schmiermittel dran
und dann flutscht es gleich besser, die Achsen sind ziemlich im Arsch, wie heißt der Typ,
Brick Experiment Channel, was ist das, Lego Powered Submarine, was für YouTube Videos
man will, das fehlt irgendwie auf YouTube Deutschland, so sinnloses interessantes Zeug,
wir haben bloß sinnloses Zeug, hab ich auch weniger aus dem, oh, ja, das wenn es fertig
ist, Online Ritter, das funktioniert nicht, ich habe ein Plugin was mir anzeigt was hinter
Wurz steckt, ich kann nicht gebated werden, zumindest nicht damit, es ist dicht, huge
Wurz, muss ich mal ein bisschen vorspulen, was gibt das wenn es fertig ist, ja ok ein
U-Boot, das wissen wir ja schon, ach guck mal, was hat er denn da, ist das ein Spannungswandler,
ich würde sagen, ne, was ist das, ach ne, das ist mal so ein Motor anzustellen, kann
das sein, ne, vielleicht erfüllst du ganz normaler Spannungswandler, keine Ahnung, ist
der jetzt auch nichts, kein Name oder so, mal gucken könnte, hatte da jetzt sein Lego
Motor dran gelötet, ach, das ist, dass er das Remote steuern kann, ja, das ist im Prinzip
wahrscheinlich wirklich, ne, das ist ein Motor, das ist irgendwas, so ein Servosteuerding
oder sowas, keine Ahnung, wenn die Leute da immer mit so uralen Lötkollen rumhantieren,
da freue ich mich immer wieder über meine nice Lötstation, jetzt wird es aber advanced
hier, ja, jetzt wird es aber advanced, fuck, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Wie gut das da reinpasst, ey, als hätte er das alles geplant.
Aber hat's ja einfach schon geplant, ne?
Oh, ist das cool!
Oh, ist das, das ist ja nice!
Ist hier mindblown!
Das müssen wir uns jetzt nochmal angucken.
Langsames, fuck, ah ja gut!
Es ist ein Lego U-Board!
Langsames, fuck, ah ja gut! Es ist ein Lego U-Board!
Kann mir einer erklären, wie das funktioniert mit dem Tauchen und Abtauchen?
Komprimiert da irgendwie die Luft da drin und, und...
Aber die Luft, die vorher drin war, die bleibt doch identisch irgendwie.
Ach, das saugt Wasser rein! Ah!
Ach so, okay, das ist natürlich noch einfacher, ja.
Du saugst Wasser rein, dann sinkst du und das, ja, okay.
Ja klar, logisch, big brain!
Das ist aber ne coole Konstruktion, die der da hat.
Oh, jetzt wird's advanced, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's richtig big brain.
Jetzt gibt er Gas, oh, jetzt, jetzt geht's ab!
Jetzt flitzt's!
Oh, es kann drehen, es kann vorwärts fahren, es kann tauchen!
Poggersboot!
Poggerscopter!
Test in the lake!
Hat der jetzt noch ne Kamera drinne?
Ich dachte auch, dass es ein Aquarium ist.
Jetzt pass auf, jetzt säuft's ab und kommt nie wieder hoch!
Der hat sogar ne Kamera drin!
Oh, das ist ja nice!
Das ist voll Poggers!
Massive Poggers!
Das ist ja geil! Das ist richtig nice!
Funktioniert!
Oh, es kommt Wasser rein, das ist natürlich schlecht.
Irgendwie nicht ganz dicht, ne?
Jawoll!
Tape!
Im Zweifelsfall, Leute!
Wenn's Probleme macht, erst mal tapen!
Immer!
Oh!
Ach, jetzt hat sogar ne Kamera nebendran!
Oh, ist es kaputt?
Nee.
Das ist ja so nice! Ich find das übelst cool, das Ding.
Guck mal, die Fische!
Die denken sich auch, was geht hier?
Jetzt noch Taser und die Fische angeln.
Das ist übelst nice!
Ich mein, es ist gleichermaßen sinnlos, aber nice!
Oh, Deep Dive!
Oh, oh je! Jetzt will er's. Gleich ist es weg!
Gleich ist es weg, Leute!
Gleich können wir Respects Payen!
Haltet schon mal eure F-Taste bereit! Ich glaube nicht, dass das U-Boot das überlebt!
Ok, es sinkt weit runter, ja.
5 Meter!
Oh, da hast du schon ganz schön...
Oh, oh, oh! Da hast du schon ganz schön Druck auf dem Ohr!
Wenn du 5 Meter taust!
Schnur dran! Ah!
So ganz funktioniert hat's nicht, oder?
Vielleicht war der Druck zu hoch? War der Druck zu hoch, irgendwie?
War 5 Meter zum Pumpen?
Wobei, fürs Wasser ist es eigentlich egal.
Nee, geht.
Sender zu schwach? Ja, kann auch sein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich Sender zu schwach. Ich mein, der konnte oben sagen,
Pump Wasser rein, und dann sinkt's, und dann konnte er halt nicht mal sagen,
Pump Wasser raus.
Doch! Doch!
Oh!
Äh, Druck zu hoch.
Druck zu hoch, ja.
Ja, F.
Aber sehr nice. Ich find das Ding cool.
Warum macht's eigentlich den Unterschied druckmäßig?
Ähm, weil ich mein, in der Spritze ist doch eigentlich nur Wasser drin.
Und Wasser rein, rauspumpen sollte doch druckmäßig keinen Unterschied machen.
Oder liegt das am Druck auf die Sache um die Spritze drum herum?
Ja, stimmt. Na klar. Doch, wenn man rauspumpt...
Intro und Ausdruck. Aha.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen komisch.
Das ist ein bisschen komisch.
Intro und Ausdruck. Aha.
Ja, klingt eigentlich logisch.
Weil du pumpst ja Sachen raus.
Das heißt, es ist im Prinzip weniger im Gehäuse drin.
Aber es sollte doch eigentlich besser gehen, oder?
Sollte es nicht eigentlich besser gehen, weil mehr draufdrückt?
Ach nee, reinpumpen. Klar, reinpumpen geht einfacher.
Ähm, weil mehr von außen reindrückt.
Also du hast ganz viel Zeug, was von außen dagegen drückt.
Das heißt, reinpumpen ist einfach.
Aber das Rauspumpen ist natürlich schwieriger.
Weil du musst ja gegen den ganzen Kram anpumpen, quasi.
Und dann wird wahrscheinlich der 12-Volt-Legomotor nicht mitmachen.
Ja, ja. Big Brain. Logik hier.
Also ich würde sagen, wir bewegen uns jetzt auf so hohem Physikniveau hier als nächstes.
Gucken wir uns in einem Video über schwarze Löcher an und lösen mal ein paar ungelöste Probleme.
Nachdem wir jetzt unser Big Brain aufgewärmt haben.
Nachdem wir das verstanden haben, was soll uns da noch in die Quere kommen?
Aber das war ein cooles Video.
Richtig cool.
Ähm, so, was kriegen wir sonst noch empfohlen?
Was? The Most Advanced Destruction Physics.
Nope.
Was? No Head, 4th Base.
Ja, Kappa, Cray Face, No Space.
2012. Nee, wann wurde Twitch?
Wann wurde Twitch?
Ich glaube, 2012 ist noch zu früh. Ja, 2014.
JustinTV hatten sie ja davor noch.
Genau.
JustinTV gab es ja schon eine ganze Weile länger.
Ob schon mal jemand geschafft hat?
Einen Lego Motor mit Propeller zu bauen, der abhebt?
Ich glaube ja nicht, dass das funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil das Ding viel zu schwer ist.
Und insgesamt viel zu langsam dreht.
Er hat es nicht gesehen. Was denn?
Oh, ein 3D. Oh nee, hör mal auf.
Die haben, die haben das nicht gesehen.
Die haben doch sogar die Leute gescampt.
Da war doch irgendwas.
Kennst du das hier, Max?
Ja, das haben wir, das haben wir, das haben wir schon gesehen hier.
Das haben wir schon gesehen hier.
Fall of 76.
Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Das war ein richtig gutes Video.
Das war ein richtig gutes Video, aber nochmal angucken wollen wir uns das nicht.
Mal eine doofe Frage.
Amletztens auf einem alten Rechner Windows 890 installiert.
Jetzt bekomme ich aber die Ladentreiber und so nicht drauf.
Ich spiele noch bei DVD-Laufwerk, weil die Treiber natürlich fehlen.
Was mache ich jetzt?
Wie? Es fehlen Treiber für ein DVD-Laufwerk?
Sowas gibt's?
Du könntest die Festplatte ausbauen und einen anderen Rechner einbauen und es da draufziehen.
Einfach Max96.
Dankeschön, Twitch Prime. Nee, nicht Twitch Prime.
So, Sub. Huge Sub.
Also nachdem jetzt YouTube uns heute irgendwie nichts mehr anzeigt, was man schönes gucken könnte.
GVD-Laufwerk, was ist das?
Ja, meine letzten drei Rechner hatten kein optisches Laufwerk mehr.
Obwohl, das habe ich hier vorher noch aufgemacht.
100% Accuracy Tactical Nuke Challenge.
Okay, was hätten wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Extremly underused, but super underrated SMG Modern Warfare.
Komm, wir gucken doch mal Modern Warfare.
Sonst wollen wir dann kurz angucken, was du noch Run'n'Gun spielen konntest.
100% Accuracy. Komm schon, bitte.
Ich konnte nicht helfen, aber das war ehrlich gesagt super.
Chris Kartoffel, Stufe 1. Dankeschön, Pog.
Könnt ihr euch noch an diese World Fast Fastest Nuke erinnern?
Wo der Typ auf Wasteland mit dem Granatenwerfer über die ganze Map genubetubt, hat 11 Kills gemacht,
hat Chopper gerne bekommen, hat und direkt nuke.
Kennt ihr das Video noch?
Das war nice, World Fastest.
Hello. Oh, der Typ war das. Oh Gott. Gibt es den überhaupt noch? Macht er noch Videos?
Hello. Macht er noch Videos?
Fuck, der macht noch Videos.
Aber so wirklich gucken tut das auch nicht.
Okay, dann machen wir noch ein Video.
Aber so wirklich gucken tut das auch keiner mehr richtig, ne?
Oder weniger. Damals hatten die Videos irgendwie 150K Aufrufe.
Hello. Ladies and Gentlemen.
Welcome to the World Fastest Tactical Nuke in 33.3 seconds.
And some of you guys may have seen this.
Ich hab mich damals über Whiteboy aufgeregt, echt.
Er hat teilweise schon fragwürdig Dinge getrieben.
But I guarantee you there's a few people who haven't.
And I wanted to re-upload this to my channel.
One, because YouTube deleted it for some reason.
Haha, guck dir den Shit an.
And I just can't.
So I wanted it to live on in history on my YouTube channel.
And two, because this is one of my proudest, if not the most proud I got in the gameplay.
Chaotic Gamer Ito, Dankeschön.
Ich mein, es ist so fail, diese Nuke eigentlich, ne?
Die Nuke ist eigentlich so fail.
Ich mein, guckt euch das an.
Der hat nichts gemacht, die ganze Runde, nichts.
Es gibt eh keinen Game Sound.
Der ist einfach gestartet, hat über die Map genoobtubt.
Hat sein Killstreak geholt, hat ein paar Gegner umgerotzt, Nuke am Start.
Du bist billig eigentlich, aber es ist schon ganz schön glücklich, dass es funktioniert hat.
Da brauchst du schon richtig Luck.
Haha, guck dir das an, richtig dumm.
Oder aber es war echt geboostet, kann auch sein.
Das würde ich denen schon zutrauen.
Aber ich mein, es ist irgendwie schon ganz cool, ja.
Der Modern Warfare 2 spawns, ich kann mir das schon vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Wenn du dir vorher anguckst, wo du hinschießen musst.
Wenn du von einer Seite auf die Flagge schießt, nach einer richtigen Zeit, das kann schon sein.
Der wird einfach geguckt haben, wie er von seinem spawnen, wie er schießen muss, dass er auf die gegnerische Flagge kommt.
Und es rennen hier alle am Anfang von der Runde, alle auf die Flagge.
So, Nuke am Start.
Das war noch ein Video.
Von wann ist denn das?
Ja, 2010.
Das war witzig, ja.
Kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Heute gehen wir für den 100% akkurativen, taktischen Nuke.
Ich werde hier einen Sniper benutzen.
Und wenn ich einen Schuss vermisse, muss ich wieder starten.
Ich war nackig, aber ich habe den Kill bekommen.
Ich will einen Schuss nehmen.
Und einen Doppelkiller.
Okay.
Ich denke, das zählt technisch als...
Die Sniper und Intervention wären MP2.
Ich habe ihn.
Ein weiterer.
5 und 0.
Wobei das die Noob-Sniper war.
Also nicht wirklich die Noob-Sniper.
Aber das war bei den krassen 360-Intervention-No-Scope-Spielern verpönt.
Diese Sniper.
Nein, nein, nein.
Harriers.
Komm schon.
Wir haben noch nicht einen Schuss vermissen.
Das sieht aus wie ein Harriers.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
10 plus 4.
Oh, ich hatte keine Aufmerksamkeit.
Ist er...
Der Intervention-Boot.
Kennst du noch CRK-Videos? Nee.
Oh Gott, das war so ein glücklicher Kill.
Was ist los, Alter?
Jemand ist hier drin.
In deinem Gesicht.
Der eine war tot.
Der Sniper war schon richtig krass in MP2.
4 Kills.
5.
Ich werde auch nicht aufräumen.
Nur damit ihr es wisst.
6 Schüsse. 6 Kills.
Oh.
Vorbeigeschossen.
Er hat vorbei geschossen. Habt ihr es gesehen?
Direkt raus. Quitten.
In... In your ass.
Die Jungs posten es.
4.
5.
Da war ein anderer Typ, oder?
Ich bin ein bisschen anspannt.
Ich weiß nicht, wo zu gehen.
7.
Nein.
Das ist wirklich gut.
7.
Nein. Nein.
Das ist wirklich gut, um von meinem Sniper zu gehen.
100% absolut komplett.
Ich konnte nicht helfen, aber nur, um zu gehen.
7.
Nein. Nein.
Das ist wirklich gut, um von meinem Sniper zu gehen.
100% absolut komplett.
Ich konnte nicht helfen, aber nur, um zu gehen.
7.
Nein. Nein.
Ich konnte nicht helfen, aber nur, um zu gehen.
Andy, Andy.
Schau dir das Video an.
Hitmarker.
Da ist dein Kopf.
2.
Der Terminal war auch gut.
4.
5.
6.
7.
Nein.
Ich konnte nicht glauben, dass ich alle Schüsse getroffen habe.
Ich werde mich auch nicht auslösen, um euch zu wissen,
dass ich alle Schüsse getroffen habe.
Ich kann mich kurz wiederholen.
Komm schon, komm schon.
8.
Oh mein Gott.
In your ass.
Ich kann mich einfach in der Ecke warten, bis die Kills die Arbeit erledigen.
Er hat gemisst mit dem Chopper-Gunner.
Ich habe es gesehen. Chopper-Gunner miss.
Aber das zählt glaube ich nicht.
Wer ist Max FPS?
Es gibt Kills, komm schon.
Ja, los geht's.
Ich werde ein paar Kommentare bekommen,
die sagen, du hast 9 Kills.
Ja, das stimmt.
Eigentlich ist es schon irgendwie beknackt.
Ich meine, 100% Accuracy Gameplay.
Was macht er?
Ich meine, ich finde es geil.
Ich gucke den echt gern.
Er macht halt 7 Kills mit der Sniper.
Und danach ist alles Killstreak.
Er ist schon ein guter Typ.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Oh, er muss Messer.
Der Messer ist die Nuke nicht valid.
Messer oder zumindest Kreisel.
Oh, keine gültige Nuke.
Nicht approved.
Komm, wir gucken gleich das nächste Video von ihm.
Ich gucke die Videos so gern,
weil es einfach nur Gameplay
und kein Gelaber dabei ist.
Ich habe letztens versucht,
MW2 zu spielen, ich habe keine Lobby gefunden.
Obwohl mein Nattyp auch offen ist.
Wohlgemerkt, ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt,
Nattyp ist eine komplette Erfindung der Konsolenhersteller.
Dieses Wort gibt es eigentlich gar nicht.
Was spielt er für eine Klasse?
Okay, was ist das?
Ist das die Uzi?
Ja.
Das Ding hat echt keiner gespielt.
Aber du kannst in MW2 alles spielen,
weil alles
komplett zerstört in Modern Warfare 2.
Es gibt eigentlich keine Waffe, die nicht schnell killt.
Das war nicht schnell die Umfall.
Oh, knapp, knapp.
Ja, natürlich bin ich Max.
Guck dir den Avatar an
und hör dir an, wie ich mich anfühle.
Klar finde ich das.
Teich es mal anders auf Twitch.
Pass auf, wieder 7 Kills Nuke, 7 Kills Nuke.
Off to a good start.
I don't want to call them in yet, dude.
There's only 4 people in this game.
3 not including myself.
Bro, they need to connect more people.
I got a pavlo.
I made that guy leave.
2 other people in the game.
This guy respawned.
I have a feeling that guy is going to leave too.
10 and 0.
Try not to do anything stupid.
I'm pretty sure that one dude is noob-tubing.
So I don't really want to run in the middle.
Holy crap, you're not dead.
I hear this dude in the middle now.
Nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben.
Das ist echt knapp.
Das ist fies.
Alter.
Alter, ist das...
Oh Gott.
Das hätte mich so aufgeregt.
Ich bin zurück. Ich bin zurück in hier, also vielleicht kann ich eine Nuke dieses Mal umdrehen. Aber jetzt habe ich nur weniger Zeit, weniger Zeit, aber ein paar mehr Leute.
Ich höre jemanden.
Wow, verdammt.
Ich werde immer noch geschossen.
Ich bin zu schwach, das Typ zu zerstören.
Der Schmerzkiller hat mich fast gekostet.
Schön.
Ich habe einen Schmerzkiller.
Jetzt erst mal Harrier.
Und dann direkt Nuke.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich werde extrem glücklich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, woher ich herkomme.
Und hier kommt eine Predmissile, die mein Harrier auslöst.
Oh fuck.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, was ich tun soll.
Was info gibt es, was ich tun soll?
Danke dir.
Ich geht es dir dirtig aus.
HASTERN
Ich bin total wütend.
So war das Teil bei dieser Person.
Wir jugkten noch ein paarashi es.
Ja, es war sehr angestehend.
Stinger, like, dude, come on.
Come on, just peek it.
Oh, they actually all had Stingers.
That makes sense.
Okay, das sind auch wieder Hubschrauber.
Everyone decides to take out a Stinger.
Aber ehrlich, man kann sowas ohne Praindead-Gegner auch nicht erspielen.
Sag ich ja immer wieder.
Deswegen, das ist das, was Cotton mit ausmacht.
Dass du auch einfach mal Games hast,
wo einfach nur übelste Bobs drin sind,
wo du mal total abgehen kannst.
Stinger, someone's still coming that way?
Seems like it.
Alright, that guy really wants to kill me, though.
I got a chance, but I don't have a lot of time.
They're cutting my chances very, very slim.
Five kills, though.
Five kills is definitely possible in less than two minutes.
Little less.
I can do this, bro.
Du hast wirklich richtig gut die Gegner gehört.
In Modern Warfare ist es so,
also im neuen,
dass sich am Anfang direkt als die Beta aufgemacht hat,
aus der PS4,
waren die Schritte extrem laut.
Du hast deine Teammates auch über die halbe Map,
du hast alles gehört.
Und im nächsten Patch,
da wo sie auch die Minimap reingepatcht haben wieder,
haben sie die Schritte irgendwie verkackt.
Seitdem hörst du nichts mehr richtig.
Du wirst so oft umlaufen,
dass du das nicht machst.
Ich habe definitiv eine Chance.
Ich habe jemanden mit einem Schmerzkiller getroffen,
der immer wieder zurück ist.
Alright, drei Kills.
Zwei Kills, Alter.
Einen Kill, Alter.
Komm, wir gehen!
Ich weiß, dass ich das oft sage, aber Alter,
die haben was gegen mich.
After all them decided to take out Stingers
and destroy one my kill shakes,
when there's only 3 other people in the game in the first place,
what other map they'll waste later, bro.
Alright, I'm gonna call this in.
I'm gonna probably switch up some attachments,
maybe Red Dot, holographic, extend mags up in Gen.
Wow, I still cannot believe that came back.
The little time remaining, the Stingers,
all odds against me, I pulled it out.
Those guys are probably so salty.
Das eine Kind hat Rage quitsch
Oh mein Gott
Wie ihr seht haben wir ein bisschen gewechselt
Ich habe einen tollen Holografik-Signal auf diesem Mini-Uzi
Es sieht ein bisschen verrückt aus
Definitiv nicht etwas, das man jeden Tag sieht
Knife
Er ist in die Granate gelaufen, verdammt
Mal sehen, ob ich hier etwas passieren kann
Terminal, da haben wir noch für die Terminal-Fans
Ja
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Oh, fuck
Oh
Oh zum Glück
Zum Glück hat der Gegner so gesackt
MW2 war auch übelst frustrierend
Aber das Schöne an MW2
Muss ich jetzt im Nachhinein echt mal so sagen
Ich hab mich auch übertrieben aufgeregt über das Game
Aber das Schöne an MW2 war
Es war alles irgendwie so OP
Dass es egal war, was du gespielt hast
Du konntest mit allem
Einen Nuke machen im Endeffekt
Weil alles so OP war
Und hat alles auch übelst schnell gekillt hat
Und die Kugeln sind dann auch
Gefühlt
Gefühlt so
Die Kugeln sind dann auch
Gefühlt durch Gegner durch
Ohne, ohne Damage zu verlieren
Du konntest den Modern Warfare 2
Acht Gegner mit dem
Sniper durchballern oder so
MW2 hatte
Hatte richtig viele Bullshit-Tode
Oh mein Gott
Geht das nur mir oder
Geht das euch auch?
Es passiert immer
Ich gehe für den Knopf
Und es geht direkt durch ihre Körper
Und dann sterbe ich
Das wäre ein klatschen Nuke
Da ist ein 4
Das waren
Scores
Die waren früher
Einfach nice
30-4
Das war noch vor der Zeit
Als man solche Scores hochgeladen hat
30-4, 30-5, 30-6
Danach hat man eigentlich nichts mehr hochgeladen
Einfach normale
Normale Gameplays
Keine 30-Flawless
95-0-Domination
Oder so
Ich frage mich warum so viele Level 1
Es gibt in Modern Warfare 2
Denken die sich 2019
Ist ein guter
2019 ist ein guter
Platz jetzt mal um anzufangen
Mit Modern Warfare 2 oder wie
Oh, hat sich selbst geharriert
Ja, es ist aber schon ein Fehler, dass er getroffen hat
Übrigens der Playdead Gegner
Oh, knapp
Die Modern Warfare 2 Dudes
Die Trickshotter
Habt ihr gesehen wie gekreiselt ist
Warum machen das die Leute in 2019 noch
Interessiert sich wirklich noch irgendjemand 2019
Für Modern Warfare 2 Trickshots
Jetzt jetzt ernsthafte Frage
Interessiert das jemand noch
Gibt es, ey, das muss ich jetzt gucken
Wartet mal, das muss ich jetzt gucken
Trickshot Montage
Und zwar dieses Jahr
Ist das neu oder ist das so eine Compilation von alten Sachen
Revolution of Trickshots
Oh Gott
Es gibt
In Modern Warfare 2
Denken die sich 2019
Ist ein guter
Es gibt
Okay, es gibt tatsächlich
Es gibt tatsächlich noch Modern Warfare Trickshot Montages
In 2019
Ernsthaft, ja
Erstmal schön Vegas Standard Text
MW2 Trickshot Montage
In 2019
Das ist echt noch ein Ding
Und heißt der Stellzoar
Heißt der Stellzoar
Ist der Stellzoar
Nee
Irgendwie hat sich der Name voll gelesen wie Stellzoar
Guckt euch den Schwachsinn an
Ich meine, es ist schon cool, es ist halt Glück dabei
Riesig viel Glück, ja
Hauptsache erstmal wie verrückt kreiseln, ja
Was auch immer
Die haben ja alle die abgedrehtesten Namen, die Trickshots
Guckt euch den Schuss an
Ja, ich warte auch noch, dass irgendwo mal der echte Sniper vom Dach springt und es Riesigsteam macht
Kennst du noch iReapz?
Ja klar, das ist die, wo alle gedacht haben, es ist ein Grill
Dabei war es halt ein Typ, der MW2 gut kreiselt
Aber es ist ein Trickshot
Dabei war es halt ein Typ, der MW2 gut gesnippert hat
iReapz, ja genau
Damit gekreiselt, was das Zeug hält
Hero LP Twitch Blimey, Dankeschön
Xtroni resubscribed, hab ich gar nicht gesehen
Dratzu2 auch, falls ihr euch nicht gesehen habt, Dankeschön für den Sub
All die musik
Oh man es gibt wirklich noch trick shots
Es gibt wirklich noch trick shots in modern warfare 2019
Ok jetzt gucken wir uns noch evolution the evolution of trick shotting an
Ok auch schöne potato interlaced quali wie von Damals
Was ist eine quali? Was ist eine quali? Wie ist eine potato quali?
Aber sowas hat man sich Damals gefreut
I want to love you
Alter mehr effekte da kriegste epileptische anfälle
Alter was ist das? The fuck? Meine Augen
Haha was geht da ab?
Und dabei noch von der map fall das war natürlich besonders stylish
Weißt ja one on one last nice
Vor allem die color effekte siehst du überhaupt nichts mehr vom game
Ja game with the kill cam so muss das sein da wurde erstmal kennt ihr das noch wo die alle wo erstmal auf die gegner
Auf die gegner erstmal 50 stuns geworfen worden dass sie sich nicht mehr bewegen können und dann wurde gekreiselt wie der weltmeister
Wie auch immer er das getroffen hat weil halt random und glück
Da blickt sie doch nicht mehr durch ich kann man sich sowas angucken
Ennig reisers entscheidet er
Jetzt wird er erstmal schön gestunt
Endi reisers entscheidet rei reisers
Man erkennt nichts ja man erkennt nichts
Warum war das denn hit warum war das denn wupp kreis das schreibe ich mir ein
Jedes jahr ist das gleiche ja es ändert sich überhaupt nichts
Ja, es ändert sich überhaupt nichts. Im ersten Jahr haben sie doch ein bisschen gequickscoped,
ansonsten wird einfach nur wie wild gekreiselt. Die kreisen sich alle ein ab. Ich fand die
Tomahawk Montages in Black Ops 1 viel geiler. The fuck? Wie trifft so was? Das ist einfach
wild im Kreis gedreht. Moment, das ist Code 4. Nee. Das ist Overclaw Remake. Kreisel,
Kreisel, Kreisel, Kreisel, Kreisel, Kreisel. Das war einfach Glück. Der ist einfach runtergesprungen,
hat gekreiselt, hat abgedrückt und hat gehofft er hittet was. Er hat was gehittet. Ich kann
mich doch echt daran erinnern, wie die Leute das Jubel abgefeiert haben, so was. Außerdem,
es fehlt die Reaction, Leute, oder? Es fehlt die Reaction. Also die Reactions fehlen schon
ein bisschen. So muss das eigentlich sein, ja? Da müssen Reactions dabei. Sag mal, haben
die ihre Sens irgendwie auf 50 oder so? Klar war der Aim Assist hart. Also vor allem, das
kannste wahrscheinlich auch nur auf der Konsole machen, dass das so funktioniert. Ui, so
fein. Fällt euch auf, dass alle Maps auch nicht super ausgefeilt waren, aber halt wenigstens
gut ausgesehen haben im MW2. Alter, macht man wirklich diese Bewegung oder ist das improvisiert?
Ich meine, was ist das hier? Da kriegst du ja... Da explodiert ja noch das Gehirn. Ui, so fein.
Da kriegst du wirklich epileptische Anfälle. Was hast du? Das hatten wir schon mal, das
hatten wir schon mal. Trickshots. Oh man. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo der Gegner war,
den er gerade getroffen hat. Wirklich nicht. Ich wüsste noch nicht mal, wo der Gegner
ist. Oh man. Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn, ja. Das war ja das riesen Ding zu MW2 Zeiten. Das war
Semtex Tactical. Jetzt gucken wir das nächste Mal. Semtex Tactical Nuke. Gibt's kein Booms
Video noch? Ja, ja. Gibt's noch. Gibt's eigentlich mittlerweile ein zweites CSU? CSU Episode 2?
Oh, haben wir doch gar nicht geguckt. CSU Episode 2. Das müssen wir gucken. Oh Gott,
das wird wieder... Das ist ja schlimmer. Die Bewertung ist ja schlechter als Diablo
Immobile. Okay, wir müssen jetzt... Oh, jetzt kommt Cringe Time. Big Brain Plays erwarten
uns jetzt. Okay, mal gucken, ob der Armin wieder am Start ist. Wo bin ich? Der Armin.
Wo ist der Armin? Ich will den Armin wieder haben. Wo ist der Armin hin? Der kommt noch.
Okay, dann bin ich ja bereut. Jetzt ist es so. Ihr habt ja die erste Folge unseres CSU
kräftig kommentiert. Und ich muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin euch dankbar dafür.
Weil ich hab's nämlich von Anfang an gesagt, dass es so nicht geht. Das muss man ruhig
machen. Sagt nicht. Was? Wer hat eigentlich den Sound abgemischt da wieder? Oh Gott, das
tut ja jetzt schon weh. Der Aufregel der Woche. Also das könnte im Hintergrund von den Effekten
könnte das auch eins zu eins aus der vorhergehenden Modern Warfare Trickshot Compilation sein,
oder? Das hat bestimmt der gleiche Typ editiert. Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil mehr Leute abgesoffen
sind auf dem Weg oder so. Da ist er. Da ist er ja wieder.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Was ist das für ein Sound gerade? Was war denn das? Was war
das? Ist das was, irgendein Porn oder? Okay, weiter. Mariano abonniert Stufe 1. Dankeschön.
Ja, das wird es natürlich alles retten.
Ja also. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Die übertreiben es mit den Kats ein bisschen, ne? Der jumpt ja von da nach da alle paar
Sekunden in die Kohle einsteigen. Wir müssen auch mehr gegen die Verschmutzung der Weltmeere
machen. Ja, da ist schon was dran. Allerdings ist halt die Frage. Der hat jetzt viel erzählt,
wenn der Tag lang ist. Aber so was sie jetzt genau machen wollen, nicht? Ich muss ja auch
gleich noch mal was zu sagen, wenn das fertig ist. Wer hat den Sound abgemischt?
Hat diese Woche in erster Runde über den Bundeshaushalt für nächstes Jahr beraten.
Dabei geht es darum, wie viel Geld unser Staat für welche Projekte ausgeben will. Also
Infrastruktur, Digitalisierung, Sicherheit und Soziales. Insgesamt geht es dabei um 360
Milliarden Euro. Das ist eine ganze Menge Geld und damit kann man echt eine Menge Projekte
voranbringen. Man darf nicht vergessen, dass, warte mal, zeig nochmal die Zahl. Das, wenn
ihr die Null weglasst, ne? Ihr lasst mal die Null weg. Also, oder ihr teilt das Ganze
mal durch 10. So viel musste der Amazon-Chef an seine Frau abdrücken bei der Scheidung.
Also, sowieso mal in Relation, ja? Da hat irgendwie 30 oder 36 irgendwie Millionen abdrücken
mussten an seine Frau. Äh, Milliarden. Milliarden, nicht Millionen. 36 Milliarden, ne?
Eine ganze Menge Geld und damit kann man echt eine Menge Projekte voranbringen, sollte man
meinen. Grüne, Linke und auch Teile der SPD sehen das anders und fordern jetzt eine kräftige
Neuverschuldung. Dann hat der Vorsitzende der Grünen, Robert Habeck, gesagt, er will
pro Jahr 35 Milliarden Euro neue Schulden in Deutschland machen. Also, für den Preis
kann man den Amazon-Gründer heiraten und sich schreien lassen. Und dafür sogar das
Grundgesetz ändern. Sie wollen unter dem Deckmantel der grünen Politik die Haushalt
in rote Zahlen treiben. Das ist ihr eigentliches Ziel. Für uns ist klar, wir wollen keine
Politik aufpummen, sondern beste Startbedingungen für die junge Generation ohne Altlast. Uns
sind drei Dinge. Wie zufrieden die junge Generation ist, sieht man ja gerade. Erstens,
keine neuen Schulden. Zweitens, Entlastungen für Familien und Arbeitnehmer. Drittens,
Investitionen in die Zukunft, in Digitalisierung und Infrastruktur. Das ist unsere Linie, die
wir durchsetzen wollen. Na denn, da wissen wir jetzt Bescheid. So, das war's für heute.
Ich sag vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen. Wenn euch die Sendung gefallen hat, dann folgt uns
doch auf Facebook, Twitter und Instagram. Abonniert unseren YouTube-Kanal. Liebe Grüße
gehen an dieser Stelle übrigens an LeFloid und SpaceFrogs. Servus Bömi, servus Gernot.
Wenn ihr das nächste Mal im Originalstudio drehen wollt, kommt gerne vorbei. Wir haben
auch immer ein kühles Bier für euch. Beruhigt die Gemüter vielleicht ein bisschen. Ein
schönes Wochenende. Servus.
Ich mein, diese Dinger sind schon irgendwie ziemlich cringe, ja. Aber so schlimm, wie
es hier dargestellt wird, von den Bewertungen her, ist das auch nicht. Ähm, wisst ihr,
was ich allgemein vermisse? Bei allen, es ist scheißegal, ob jetzt CSU, SPD, AfD, FDB,
egal. Was ich bei allen vermisse, das ist, dass man irgendwie einen nachvollziehbaren
Plan aufstellen würde, den man auch regelmäßig kontrollieren kann. Es wird meistens gesagt,
oh Mist, Infrastrukturkacke, oh Klima, hier Einwanderung, hier Abwasser geht nicht richtig,
Straßen gehen mehr kaputt, was auch immer. Und dann kommt jemand auf die Idee und sagt,
ja, also bis 2045 hätte ich da einen ganz tollen Plan, wie das alles super wird. Ganz
ehrlich, 2045 interessiert keine Sau. 2045 ist komplett aus der Luft gegriffen. Und außerdem
gibt es ja, ist das ja auch alles immer überhaupt nicht verbindlich. Guckt mal, die letzten,
ich sag jetzt einfach mal 15 Jahre, Infrastruktur, Internetausbau, wir haben in keinem einzigen
Jahr, wir haben in keinem einzigen Jahr unsere Ziele, die wir gesetzt haben, erreicht. Wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dann, dass wenn wir uns jetzt Ziele setzen für 2045 oder 2030,
wo die Leute, die es beschlossen haben, teilweise gar nicht mehr leben, dass sich da irgendjemand
noch verbindlich dran hält. Das ist nicht vorhanden. Das juckt keinen mehr. Das ist
in ein paar Jahren komplett vergessen. Und dann ist es 2029 und man sagt, ja, wir werden
die Ziele, ne, man wartet bis 2031 und sagt, ja, wir haben die Ziele knapp verfehlt, was
im Endeffekt heißt, man hat eigentlich nichts davon umgesetzt. Außerdem, finde ich, gehen
die Diskussionen ein bisschen dran, an der Realität oftmals vorbei. Ich finde die Diskussion
drüber, so nach dem Motto, Heizung verbieten oder irgendwelche Autogeschichten verbieten
oder Fliegen irgendwie verbieten oder was auch immer, ich finde das nicht gerade zielführend,
weil das sorgt dafür, dass viele Leute aus Trotz quasi sagen, ey, da bin ich überhaupt
nicht dafür, alles scheiße. Du kannst nicht von heute auf morgen irgendwas verbieten.
Was man eigentlich machen müsste, meiner Meinung nach, du müsstest einen ordentlichen
Plan aufstellen, zum Beispiel nehmen wir mal die Bahn. Du müsstest einen Plan aufstellen,
sagen wir jetzt, bis 2025 wollen wir das und das erreicht haben, Infrastrukturausbau bei
der Bahn und da wird jeden Monat, jedes Jahr, wird da kontrolliert, ob das eingehalten
wird. Also es darf nicht nur ein Zieldatum mit einer Wunschvorstellung geben, sondern
es muss einen Plan geben, wie man da hinkommt, wie man das Ganze erreichen kann und das Ding
muss nicht nur kontrolliert werden. Wenn das kontrolliert wird und nicht eingehalten
wird, muss irgendwas passieren und nicht so nach dem Motto, oh, ihr seid böse, ihr habt
den Plan nicht eingehalten und haltet ihn das nächste Mal ein. Nee, dann werden die
Typen einfach rausgeschmissen oder irgendjemand daran beteiligt ist und es verkackt hat und
Leute hingesetzt, die das können. Und dann, wenn man es geschafft hat, dass man Alternativen
geschafft hat, zum Beispiel bei einer Bahn, also wenn man Alternativen zum Auto geschafft
hat, indem man den Nahverkehr besser ausbaut, dann werden viele Leute, denke ich, auch von
alleine auf die Idee kommen und sagen, ja okay, so schlecht ist es doch gar nicht. Weil
aktuell, was würden passieren, wenn du jetzt sagen würdest, irgendwie, ist ja jetzt schon
so, dass du manchmal in die Innenstädte nicht fahren darfst mit dem Auto. Das Problem ist,
dass wenn es keine Alternativen gibt, was bleibt denn den Leuten übrig, außer das
zu boykottieren oder irgendwas anderes zu wählen, was halt das nicht möchte. Den Leuten
bleibt ja gar nichts anderes übrig. Du musst gucken, dass du Alternativen schaffst, so
benutzbar, dass es die Leute auch irgendwie überzeugt. Und wenn du das hast, dann werden
viele Leute freiwillig sagen, okay, ich fahre morgens nicht mehr mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt.
Und wenn du Alternativen hast, dass es möglich ist, dein Leben normal zu leben, ohne Auto,
ja, dann kann man sich überlegen, ob man sagt, okay, man verbietet jetzt nicht irgendwie
bestimmte Sachen. Aber du kannst nicht anfangen mit, ich verbiete was, aber es gibt keine
Alternativen. Es reicht nicht, wenn es einen Plan gibt, dass es in 30 Jahren Alternativen
gibt. Das bringt ja den Leuten heute auch nichts. Was willst du den Leuten erzählen,
die beispielsweise gerade so über die Runden kommen und denen sagst du jetzt, ja, ihr müsst
jetzt für 15.000 Euro eure Heizung ausbauen. Das machen die nicht. Im Zweifelsfall selbst
sollte es ein Gesetz geben, die werden sich nicht dran halten. Die warten dann halt drauf,
bis irgendwas passiert. Wie soll denn das funktionieren? Du brauchst erst ordentlich
Alternativen und einen verbindlichen und nachvollziehbaren Weg, wie man da hinkommt. Und wenn man das
hat, aber wir haben es halt nicht so, wenn man das hat und es immer noch ein paar Hardcore-Leute
gibt, die meinen, sie müssen das andere machen, obwohl es Alternativen gibt, dann kann man
sich überlegen, ob man das Ganze verbietet. Aber ansonsten wirst du meiner Meinung nach
nie die breite Masse an Leuten abholen und überzeugen. Dann hast du dann eher Leute,
die quasi, wie nennt man das so, so aus Prinzip bin ich jetzt dagegen, so aus Prinzip nicht.
Wenn ihr mir das hier jetzt wegnimmt, dann wähle ich AfD. Wenn ihr das hier mir wegnimmt,
dann kauft mir einen SUV. Wenn ihr mir das hier wegnimmt, dann keine Ahnung, dann, wisst
ihr, da hast du ganz viele Leute, die du dadurch schaffst, die quasi gerade sagen, jetzt erst
recht nicht. Ich finde scheiße, wie das läuft, ich machs jetzt erst recht. Und deswegen
ist glaube ich, verbieten jeder falsche Ansatz. Du kannst das verbieten, sobald es Alternativen
gibt, aber wir sind halt nicht gut, wir sind halt nicht gut da drin. Ich finde, es hat
nen Sinn, äh, kein Sinn, es gibt, ich hab letztens gelesen, die SUV-Zulassungsrate ist
seit Jahren dieses Jahr gestiegen. Und übrigens, man muss auch dazu sagen, SUVs sind nicht
gefährlicher als andere Autos oder so, gibt es auch Statistiken drüber, ihr wisst, ich
fahre eigentlich so gut wie gar kein Auto, aber das Geh- also das, ähm, Gehater auf
SUVs weiß ich nicht, inwieweit das, inwieweit das gerechtfertigt ist, aber ich glaube,
dass die, der Anstieg der Zulassungsrate ein bisschen Protest ist von, äh, diesen Leuten,
die sich quasi gerade verarscht vorkommen. Wisst ihr, wenn, wenn man, wenn man diskutiert
so nach dem Motto, oh, sollen wir, sollen wir Ölheizung abschaffen, oh, sollen wir
SUVs verbieten, da sagen ganz viele Leute, hey, ihr könnt mich am Arsch lecken, ich
kauf mir jetzt einen neuen SUV, oder ihr könnt mich jetzt am Arsch lecken, dann, dann
upgrade ich nochmal meine Heizung. Ja, also, ich finde, das geht irgendwie in die nicht-
sondern nicht-produktive Richtung, ja. Außerdem, gerade bei dieser Klimageschichte, sollte
es ja eigentlich nicht so sehr darum gehen, wer irgendwas, irgendwas fühlt, oder irgendwas,
äh, meint, ähm, das kann man ja glücklicherweise, gibt's ja zu diesem Thema mehr Studien, wie
zu fast allem anderen auch, ähm, das hat eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn, irgendwie auf diese
Art und Weise da zu argumentieren. Also, ich weiß nicht, ich find's nicht zielführend,
dass das Ganze gerade gemacht wird. Ich denke, wir müssten zum Beispiel im Nahverkehr, was
Bahn und sowas angeht, da müsste man so viel machen, es muss möglich sein, dass du innerhalb
von 10 Minuten in ein öffentliches Verkehrsmittel bei dir steigen kannst, ohne dass du dir großartig
Gedanken machen musst vorher, du gehst einfach hin an Bahnhof oder an die Haltestelle, du
musst in den nächsten Zug steigen und du musst ankommen, wo du hin willst. Und wenn
das, wenn man das hinkriegt, dann sagen ganz viele Leute freiwillig, ey, ich fahr doch
nicht, ich bin doch nicht blöd, ich fahr doch nicht mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt. Aber aktuell
ist es halt genau das Gegenteil der Fall. Und wir haben es in den letzten Jahren gesehen,
dass wir nicht in der Lage sind, Ziele einzuhalten, die wir haben. Guckt euch, guckt euch Breitbandausbau
in Deutschland an. Wie gesagt, das sind 15 Jahre in Folge, wo wir den Kram nicht eingehalten
haben. So, und wie weltfremd das Ganze ist, sieht man ja daran. Nee, Regierungssprecher.
Die Weltfremd das Ganze ist, sieht man ja daran. Wo ist es denn? Ich zeige euch das
mal. Ich finde den Tweet nicht mehr. Ja, hier. Ey, fuck, wo ist es denn? Wo man mal sieht,
wie weltfremd der ganze Kram ist. Hier, genau. Wir haben gepostet 2017. Entgegen allem, was
bekannt ist, es war zu diesem Zeitpunkt meiner Ansicht nach klar, dass diese Aussage nicht
haltbar ist, komplett utopisch. 2017. Und trotzdem stellt man sich hin und tut so, als
wäre das was, was easy machbar ist. Und solange solche Pläne und Aussagen getroffen werden,
obwohl man weiß, dass es nicht funktioniert, wie soll man denn da Vertrauen drauf haben,
dass bis 2030 irgendwas passiert? 50 Mbit ist viel zu langsam. Ja, das mag sein, allerdings
haben die Leute ja noch nicht mal 50 Mbit. Ich meine, schaffen solche Aussagen in irgendeiner
Art und Weise Vertrauen dahin, dass wenn jetzt quasi die gleichen Leute sagen, bis 2030,
bis 2040 wird XY passieren, wer glaubt da ernsthaft noch dran, dass bis 2040 XY auch
passieren wird? Und das hier, hier reden wir von einem bis zwei Jahren, die nicht einfach
nur nicht eingehalten werden, sondern meilenweit daneben liegen. Also hier reden wir von eins
bis zwei Jahren, die absolut nicht zutreffen. Wer glaubt denn dann wirklich dran, dass in
einem Zeitraum von 10 bis 20 Jahren Pläne, die heute gemacht werden, auch nur ansatzweise,
auch nur ein Furz entfitzelchen davon eingehalten werden? Das kann man doch keinem erklären.
So viel zum Thema. Und solange das so weitergeht, also diese ganze, dass so viele Leute, die
Leute das Gefühl haben, dass ihre Interessen nicht ernst genommen werden, umso mehr werden
Leute AfD wählen. Es ist vollkommen bescheuert, davon auszugehen, dass alle AfD-Wähler Nazis
sind. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Leute immer auf die Idee kommen. Das sind einfach zum
größten Teil Leute, ja mit Sicherheit haben die auch solche Leute, aber das sind einfach
zum größten Teil Leute, die sich sagen, die einfach nichts anderes mehr wissen. Die einfach
nicht mehr wissen, was sie sonst wählen sollen. Die sind einfach abgefuckt. Und dass die AfD
so viele Prozente hat, liegt nicht daran, dass die AfD an sich so geil wäre oder dass
die Inhalte, die Leute wahnsinnig überzeugen werden oder dass alles böse Nazis sind. Nein,
das liegt daran, dass die Leute einfach absolut kein Vertrauen mehr haben zu dem, was sie
bisher gewählt haben. Und im Prinzip liegt es nicht daran, dass die AfD so geil ist und
dass es die anderen so verkacken, dass sie so viele neue Wähler bekommen. Und es ist
ja auch vollkommen, wo war das jetzt in Thüringen oder in Sachsen? Wo hat die AfD 27% gekriegt
oder 25%? 25%, es ist komplett weltfremd wirklich anzunehmen, 25% wären irgendwie Nazis von
diesen Leuten. Außerdem, dieser Begriff wird mittlerweile so inflationär irgendwie verwendet,
wenn heute irgendjemand sagt, so nach dem Motto, ja, ich bin nicht zufrieden mit, keine
Ahnung, was sind da irgendwie ein schönes Thema? Ich bin nicht zufrieden mit Einwanderungspolitik
oder ich bin nicht zufrieden mit, keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal, mit Einwanderungspolitik.
Es reicht ja heute schon die Aussage, dass dann gleich eine ankommt, scheiß Nazi, was
auch absolut nicht zielführend ist, was nur noch mehr dazu beiträgt, dass die Leute sich
nicht verstanden fühlen und immer mehr der Meinung sind, ihre Probleme und Ängste letztendlich
werden nicht ernst genommen und dann erst recht. Ich glaube, das größte Problem ist, dass
die Leute verunsichert sind und teilweise sogar Angst davor haben, was kommt, bzw.
wie es läuft und dass sie ihre Ängste und Probleme nicht eins genommen fühlen und deswegen
AfD wählen und nicht, weil irgendwie 25% der Leute Nazis sind. Und solange das nicht
angegangen wird, den Leuten, die aus diesem Grund AfD wählen, solange man diese Leute
nicht adressiert, wird das mehr werden. Und es hat auch keinen Sinn sich dann hinzustellen
und zu sagen, oh, das sind alles böse Nazis, weil das trifft man den meisten Leuten schlicht
und greift nicht zu. Und außerdem muss ich noch mal sagen, ich finde es ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich beschissen, dass mittlerweile heute alles als Nazi betitelt wird, aus dem einfachen
Grund, weil dann diese Aussage überhaupt keine Gewicht mehr hat. Wenn alles mittlerweile
ein Nazi ist, ist nichts mehr ein Nazi. Und ich meine, ist es gerechtfertigt, jemand,
der, sagen wir mal jemand, der AfD wählt, weil er nicht zufrieden ist mit allen anderen
Parteien, ist es gerechtfertigt, diese Leute quasi gleich mit Massenmördern zu vergleichen?
Ich finde, das ist auch wie gesagt überhaupt nicht zielführend bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Und es wird mehr werden. Dadurch, dass immer mehr Leute unzufrieden sind und die denken
sich, jetzt siehst du eine SUV Zulassrate, die denken sich jetzt erst recht. Naja, ich
verstehe es. Also ich glaube, wir fahren, also das wird gerade richtig an die Wand gefahren
und ohne, dass es irgendwie gecheckt wird. Naja, gut. So viel dazu. Ich habe übrigens
keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll. Selbstzerstörung, ja, vieles ist tatsächlich, vieles ist hausgemacht.
Also ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll. Und eins muss ich jetzt auch
noch mal sagen, danach waren wir hier mit Polit-Talk Schluss. Es wird an vielen Stellen
immer so getan, als hätte Deutschland viel Geld. Also wer sich das mal anguckt, wie sich
das die letzten 20, 30 Jahre entwickelt hat, weiß ich nicht, wo das ganze Geld hingeht.
Infrastruktur ist immer beschissener, sei es ist es egal, Straßenkanalisation, Internetausbau,
Gesundheitskram ist immer schlechter, Renten sind schlechter. Wenn ich mir angucke, wie
viele Rentner mittlerweile am Bahnhof sind und Flaschen sammeln, es gibt ganz viele Punkte.
Es gibt wirklich, ich habe mir irgendwann mal eine Liste gemacht, das irgendwie mit,
keine Ahnung, mit 30 Punkten, wo man wirklich nicht nur gefühlt, sondern wo man auch nachgucken
kann. Das ist mehr geworden und das ist schlechter geworden die letzten Jahre. Und trotzdem haben
wir theoretisch insgesamt mehr Geld. Da frage ich mich erstens, wohin das Geld geht und zweitens,
wenn man sich das mal genauer anguckt, wird man feststellen, wir haben gar nicht mehr
Geld. Also sagen wir so, die normalen Leute, das was die Großteil der Bevölkerung darstellt,
die haben nicht wirklich so extrem viel mehr Geld. Ich meine, uns geht es hier gut, keine
Frage. Wir haben zwar in Deutschland insgesamt mehr Geld, aber die meisten Leute, wie es
betrifft, die haben nicht mehr Geld. Und ich glaube, das größte Problem, was wir haben
oder das mit größte Problem, was viele Länder haben, denen es die letzten Jahre sehr gut
ging, ist, dass die Schere zwischen den Leuten, die extrem viel haben und zwischen den Leuten,
die nichts haben, immer weiter auseinandergeht. Die letzten Jahre schon auseinandergegangen
ist und jetzt immer weiter auseinandergeht. Also, dass du quasi einen ganz kleinen Prozentsatz
an Leuten hast, die so viel haben wie 80 Prozent vom Rest. Da sieht es natürlich im
Durchschnitt aus, als hätten wir wahnsinnig viel mehr Geld, ist aber nicht so. Weil ansonsten
muss man sich fragen, wohin geht denn das Geld, wenn die letzten 20, 30 Jahre in vielen
Bereichen, wie gesagt, Gesundheitszeug, Infrastruktur, Rentenzeug, das nicht besser geworden ist
oder schlechter geworden ist. Man kann nicht alles für Berater ausgeben, ja. Ich glaube,
das ist das Problem, was viele Länder haben und wir auch, dass die Schere zwischen Arm
und Reich immer größer wird. Und daher kommen auch viele Probleme, die wir jetzt aktuell
haben, nämlich, dass gerade die Schichten an Leuten, die nichts haben oder sag mal so,
wo einer weniger hat als der andere, dass die anfangen gegeneinander ausgespielt zu
werden. Du hast dann zum Beispiel einen Hartz-IV-Empfänger, du hast, keine Ahnung, du hast Flüchtlinge,
Hartz-IV-Empfänger, Langzeitarbeitslose, Rentner mit wenig Einkommen, mit wenig Geld,
die sich alle gegenseitig abfacken, weil der eine 5 Euro mehr als der andere hat. Und die
sind da sehr damit beschäftigt, sich untereinander abzufacken. Wobei der Auslöser eigentlich
ganz woanders ist. Ich glaube, das ist das eigentliche Problem, was wir haben. Vieles
andere sind Symptome davon. Weil irgendwo muss die Kohle ja hingehen. Und ich denke
auch, dass die Aussage, wir sind zu reich, wir haben so viel Geld schlicht und ergreifend
nicht stimmt. Wir brauchen jeden Euro, den wir haben. Guckt euch das mal an, wenn ihr
heute sagt, mir tut keine Ahnung, mir tut das Knie weh und ihr wollt zu einem Orthopäde,
das ist einfach nur ein Beispiel. Da kann es durchaus sein, wenn ihr in der Stadt wohnt,
da gibt es dann vielleicht sogar 15 Erze, wo ihr hingehen könnt, ihr müsst ein halbes
Jahr warten. Ihr müsst ein halbes Jahr warten und wenn ihr hinkommt, werdet ihr innerhalb
von 5 Millionen abgefertigt. Das ist ein Zustand, deswegen bezahle ich so Sachen auch gerne
mal privat, weil man einfach schlicht und ergreifend besser behandelt wird. Das ist
halt auch so was, das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Für das, dass es uns doch angeblich
so gut geht, das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Guckt euch das mal in Dänemark an. In Dänemark
bezahlen theoretisch Anteile sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Steuern als wir, aber da ist
es ein komplett anderes Bild. Die haben sogar Kindergartenplätze, stellt euch das mal vor.
Die haben Kindergartenplätze, die haben Ernste, wo du hingehen kannst. Das heißt, irgendwo
muss die Kohle hinfließen, aber das ist halt das Problem, wenn die Kohle nicht fließt,
dann bei 0,01% der Leute ist die halt alles haben. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass diese
Leute irgendwie böse, schlecht oder sonst was sind. Ich meine, viele davon haben sich
die Kohle erarbeitet, verdient, viele haben sie geerbt mittlerweile. Aber ich glaube,
das ist das hauptsächliche Problem, was wir haben, dass wir zwar auf dem Papier viel
Geld haben, trotzdem der Großteil der Bevölkerung halt eben nicht diese Kohle in der Tasche
hat. Und dass gerade eben die Schichten, die eh kein Geld haben, dass die gegeneinander
ausgespielt werden und ja, dass es dann so läuft, wie es jetzt läuft. Ah, unter anderem
auch ein Grund, warum so viele Leute AfD wählen. Nicht, weil sie Nazis sind, weil sie einfach
unzufrieden sind mit allem anderen. Ich habe es ja gemerkt, ich war jetzt bei ein paar
Ärzten, nichts wildes, ich hatte bloß kein Bock, das halbes Jahr zu warten. Ich habe
da angerufen, beispielsweise beim Hautarzt, hinten am Kopf hatte ich irgendwie so einen
Ausschlag oder so was, wo ich nicht wusste, wo das herkommt. Wahrscheinlich hat sich das
irgendwie entzündet und man sieht es ja mittlerweile auch gut, weil ich hinten nicht mehr so viele
Haare habe auf dem Kopf. Und da habe ich mal in Hanau beim Hautarzt angerufen, habe gesagt,
wie sieht es denn aus? Ich habe irgendwas auf dem Kopf, keine Ahnung, was das ist, ob
ich das mal angucken kann. Und er hat gesagt, wo du anrufst? Er hat gesagt, ja, kein Ding,
halbes Jahr. Ich habe gesagt, okay, in einem halben Jahr ist entweder mein Kopf abgefault
oder es ist wieder weg. Dann habe ich angerufen in Frankfurt bei einem Hautarzt und habe
gesagt, also ich bezahle selbst. Und da haben die gesagt, ja, wann passt es Ihnen denn?
Ich habe gesagt, ja, um 12 Uhr habe ich Mittagspause. Ich habe gesagt, ja, kommen Sie morgen 12
Uhr vorbei. Das ist also die Aussage, die teilweise getroffen wird, wir müssen aufpassen,
dass wir keine 2 Klassenmedizin kriegen, ist vollkommen an der Realität vorbei. Wir
haben eine 2 Klassenmedizin. Es ist nicht so, dass wir keine kriegen, wir müssen aufpassen,
wir haben die. Was zahlt man da so? Das kriegst du relativ einfach raus. Du musst dir einfach
mal ein paar Listen angucken. Es gibt im Internet ganz viele Listen, wo jede Behandlung einen
Preis dranstehen hat. Und privat bezahlst du diesen Preis mal 2,3 bis maximal mal 3,
was da drauf steht. Das heißt, ich habe im Endeffekt 50 Euro bezahlt für die Untersuchung
beim Hautarzt, inklusive angucken und Zeugs drauf schmieren. Das geht, das geht. Wo es
natürlich richtig ins Geld geht, ist wenn du wirklich größere Behandlungen brauchst,
das geht natürlich ins Geld. Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie Röntgen-MAT machen musst
oder längere Behandlungen, das geht natürlich richtig ins Geld, wenn du das privat bezahlen
musst. Es hat sich einfach ein bisschen entzündet, nichts Wildes. Sie hat sich das angeguckt,
dann haben wir uns noch angeguckt, was in meinem Haarwaschmittel für Allergie-Zeug
drin ist. Meint, ja, das könnte daran liegen, sie schreibt mir jetzt was auf, das habe ich
dann irgendwie eine Woche draufgeschmiert und dann war es wieder weg. Also so Kleinkram,
nur Kleinkram bezahle ich mittlerweile selbst, weil es einfach viel angenehmer ist. Ja, also
es gibt, wir haben, meiner Ansicht nach haben wir eindeutig schon eine, zwei Klassen Medizin.
Es ist ein riesen Unterschied, ob du privat versichert bist oder selbst bezahlst, was
unterm Strich kein Unterschied ist, ja, für die zum Abrechnen oder ob du gesetzlich versichert
bist. Ich bin mir, ich bin ernsthaft am Überlegen gerade, ob ich mich nicht privat versichern
soll. Ich meine, man sagt ja so bis 35, wo sollte man sich entscheiden? Ich bin jetzt
35, noch ein Jahr lang, ob ich das nicht mache. Ich meine, es kostet ein Schweinegeld. Es
kostet ein Schweinegeld, ja. Aber wenn man mal wirklich was hat, was vielleicht auch
ein bisschen länger und ein bisschen größer ist, dann ist man vielleicht noch mal froh,
ja. Wenn du Kohle, genug Kohle hätte ich dafür. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob ich die bereift bin
auszugeben. Deswegen bin ich Beamter, ja, das ist natürlich auch eine Variante. Wobei
zum Thema Beamte, ich habe letztens mal geguckt, ich verdiene genug, ja, könnte das machen.
Außerdem habe ich ja theoretisch noch eine eigene Firma und als Selbstständiger darfst
du eh. Ja, ich habe letztens mal geguckt, weil jemand geschrieben hat, der ist Beamter.
Ich habe letztens mal geguckt, ich habe eine Stellenanzeige gesehen von der Bundeswehr
und eine Stellenanzeige von der Polizei und die hatte ich mir mal angeguckt und was du
da verdienst, ist schon im Vergleich zu dem, was man sonst so verdient, nicht viel. Muss
man sagen. Gut, ich meine, klar, du hast wahrscheinlich steuerliche Vorteile und vielleicht wirst du
irgendwann auch mal Beamter und hast dann günstige Tarife, aber irgendwie Krankenversicherungen
und allem. Aber das, was da unter dem Schrift rauskommt, war nicht so viel. Bekommst du von
deinem YouTube-Channel eigentlich noch Geld? Ja, mittlerweile schon, ja. Mittlerweile
schon. Also ich würde mal sagen, diesen Monat, ich mache jetzt ungefähr einen Monat mache
ich jetzt ja wieder Videos. Also ich würde sagen, das ist der erste Monat jetzt, so ungefähr,
wenn man mal die Sellout-Geschichten mitrechnet, wenn man mal Twitch mitrechnet, wahrscheinlich
so 2500 bis 3000 Euro, ohne Steuern, ne? Twitch-Subs, Sellout, YouTube-Money, dürften
so 2500 Euro so in dem Dreh ungefähr sein. Alter, da muss ich noch Steuern drauf bezahlen,
ne? Also kannst du die Hälfte schon mal wegrechnen von. Also sagen wir mal so, es bleibt noch
irgendwie 1600 oder so übrig. Sagen wir mal, 1500 bleiben übrig irgendwie. Da ist aber
wirklich alles dabei. Da ist der Ubisoft Sellout dabei, da ist AdSense dabei und da sind Twitch-Subscriber
dabei. Twitch-Subscriber machen ja alleine schon quickmaps, irgendwie 900 Euro oder so
aus. Dann gab es den Ubisoft Sellout, der auch nochmal ordentlich was gebracht hat. Donation-Button,
den habe ich weggemacht, weil das Donation-Bidget verbackt war und ja AdSense. Wenn ich wieder
anfangen würde, also müsste ich mal überlegen, was war angenommen realistisch? Ich würde
wirklich mir mal Mühe geben, also sprich auch wieder Amazon Reflings generieren, vielleicht
die ein oder anderen Sachen abschließen, so wieder was wie ich zum Beispiel mit Elgato
gemacht habe. Keyshop, nee, meine CPM sind nicht so der Wahnsinn. Keyshop mache ich nicht
mehr. Bevor ich wirklich anfange Hardcore Sellout zu machen, mache ich mir lieber einen
Patreon-Account oder sowas und da kann jeder, der will, was geben. Also wie gesagt, angenommen
ich würde es mal richtig machen mit allem, was irgendwie noch erträglich ist. Also kein
Keyshop, kein Keyshop-Geschiss. Also wenn ich ordentlich Amazon Reflings mache, ich denke
mal, dann sind es so relativ gut, würde ich mal sagen, so 3000€ im Monat, wo man auch
Steuern drauf bezahlen muss, drin. Wenn ich es weiter so beibehalten würde wie jetzt,
also ohne den übertriebenen Sellout zu machen, ab und zu mal die ein oder andere Promotion,
ich denke 1-2 Mal im Monat ist das okay. Und mittlerweile bringt der Kram halt echt Kohle.
Wenn ich mir überlege, am Anfang 2010 auf YouTube, da hast du dich schon gefreut, wenn
du eine Maus gekriegt hast oder ein Spiel umsonst gekriegt hast. Und mittlerweile geht das los
im 4-stelligen Bereich. Das ist der Witz mittlerweile, wenn man sich überlegt, was man für einfache
Sachen eigentlich mittlerweile bekommt. Und ich überlege mir da immer, wenn ich das schon
angeboten bekomme, was bekommt dann erst jemand angeboten, wie, keine Ahnung, wie Shroud oder
XQC oder Montana Black oder was haben wir da sonst noch. Ganz extrem, was bekommt dann
erst der PewDiePie angeboten, Alter. Ninja, was bekommt Ninja angeboten? Oder der Nico,
ja. Ich meine, wenn ich überlege, dass es bei mir schon ein niedriger 4-stelliger Betrag
ist für ein bisschen Video und Sellouts, okay. Und bei mir gucken, keine Ahnung, 30.000 Leute
oder so den Kram, inklusive Twitter und allem. Wie ist es dann erst bei jemandem, wo das
eine halbe Million oder zwei Millionen gucken? Ninja muss doch für einen Sellout-Stream einfach
mal, keine Ahnung, 350.000 Euro kriegen oder so. Ninja für den Wechsel auf Mixer. Zwei-stelliger
Millionenbetrag bestimmt. Einfach mal so ins Blaue geschossen. Also zwei-stelliger Millionenbetrag
bestimmt. Was Inscope21Realtalk, Nico unterstützt seinen Vater beim Hausbau. Ja, der Nico macht
das richtig. Nico macht das richtig. Nicht so diese Korean Savage-Geschichte, wo ich
brauche Spenden für meinen Vater und danach zeige ich euch mein neues geiles Gamingzimmer.
Ja, klar. Man darf aber nicht immer nur, das sind ja die absoluten Top-Leute, ja, wenn
du sowas wie Montara Black anguckst oder PewDiePie oder sowas. Das sind ja die 0,0001% der Leute.
Der überwiegende Teil der Content-Creator wird damit nicht reich. Der überwiegende
Teil der professionellen Content-Creator, der kommt damit, denke ich mal, gut über die
Runden, weil sonst macht das nicht lang. Aber die meisten werden damit nicht reich. Das
Nico ist gebannt? Echt, warum ist Nico gebannt? Aber nicht auf YouTube, auf Twitch, oder?
Hat er irgendwie einen Hintern gezeigt oder so? Auf Twitch, okay. Lull. Hat kleine Channel
geratet. Seine Community hat gegratet. Was kann er dann dafür? Leute, ich habe 300 Zuschauer.
Das ist ja in den letzten paar Minuten gesübelst hochgegangen von 250 auf 300. Willkommen im
Stream, alle. Ich darf nicht über ihn sprechen. Ah, sollen sie mich anzeigen. Ist echt, man
kann es nicht gut vergleichen. Wie gesagt, die top 0,1%, das heißt nicht nur, weil die
massig Kohle scheffeln. Wie gesagt, guckt euch Ninja an oder Montana Black oder guckt
ihr. Beim Nico weiß ich, kann ich schlecht einschätzen, aber der wird auch ordentlich
Kohle verdienen. Das kann man nicht vergleichen mit normalen Leuten, die irgendwie ihre 50k
pro Video haben und keine Ahnung, 2, 3, 4, 5 Millionen im Monat und vielleicht die ein
oder anderen Promotions. Um auf das Jahresgehalt zu kommen, was man im normalen Job verdient,
muss man schon creator-mäßig recht gut im Geschäft sein. Und es kommt auch ein bisschen
auf den Bereich an, in dem man am Start ist. Wenn man jetzt, sag mal, im Gaming-Entertainment-Lifestyle-Bereich
ist, da mag es vielleicht noch ein bisschen einfacher sein. Wenn du im Technikbereich
bist, wahrscheinlich nicht, außer du bist Linus Tech Tips. Nico hat mit seiner Firma
im Millionenbereich. Ja, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Das ist aber halt nicht auf den
normalen Content-Creator Zugriff. Der kommt damit, denke ich mal, ganz gut über die Runden,
aber irgendwie Millionär werden sie nicht. Machst du jetzt Beauty? Ja, dann muss ich
den Friseur mal wieder dazu überreden. Dann machen wir Beauty-Tips. Ah, gut.
Credit-Druck-Video. Ist der Friseur on? Der Cryin' wird bestimmt wieder im Kreis. Was
hast du auf alle... Oh, der Fabian ist am Start. Wie lange ist er denn schon on? Da ist er.
Der Frazier. Der Frazier ist am Start. Wie lange ist er denn schon on? Warum kriege ich
nicht angezeigt, wie lange er schon on ist? 15 Minuten ist er eben gerade on gekommen.
So, und da hat sich ver... Ja, mittlerweile hat er an vielen Stellen Tätowierungen. Aber
ansonsten, wenn ihr euch anhört, das ist ja immer noch der Frazier 1 zu 1. Da wird in
so gekrindet. Man könnte die Quali ein bisschen hoch machen. Ihr könnt ja mal bei ihm vorbeigucken.
Mein Game war BDO leider nicht. Ich würde sagen, wir hosten den Frazier jetzt. Was ist
eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Raid und Host? Ich habe keine Ahnung, so viel zum
Thema Twitch. Wieso sind meine Boden weg? Hä? What? By host, gehst du off. Raiding someone
brings viewers who join from your channel to the raid target. Hosting someone just shows
the stream. Ah, das heißt, es switched automatisch. Okay. Dann raiden wir jetzt den Frazier. Also
Leute, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen. Stream. 2 Stunden 15. Nice. Schön, dass so viele
Leute am Start gewesen sind. Wir raiden jetzt den Frazier. Macht es gut. Wir sehen uns vielleicht
heute Abend, aber wahrscheinlich erst morgen. Videotechnisch wieder. Oder streamen vielleicht.
Mal gucken. Macht es gut. Bis dann. See you. Oh, jetzt wird geradet. Mal gucken, wie das
funktioniert.